welcome to screen crush my name is ryan
airy
got you it is i heavy spoilers god of
mischief and tricks
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down the newest episode of loki
episode 3 has us at the halfway point of
the season and it's packed with easter
eggs hidden details and things that you
might miss
however we are here to recap the entire
thing from top to bottom
and in this review we'll be pointing out
all the low key details
now last week we came face to face with
the mysterious hooded figure that had
been terrorizing the tva
though this was simply thought to be
lady loki eagle-eyed viewers spotted
some clues in the episode that showed
she might be someone else
the international credits revealed that
her name was sylvie and this was
confirmed
by her file in the episode sylvie is a
blonde hair
marvel universe character that was born
in oklahoma
and she was actually given powers by
loki now i will be discussing this
theory later on in the video
and how she might just be an
amalgamation but with her clearly
pulling from lady loki
i thought we'd discuss her main arc in
the comics and then later on in the
video we can branch off into the
speculation
as always time codes will be linked
below so if you want to skip straight to
the recap then use the power of your
favorite green paperweight to jump ahead
now over the years the god of mischief
has taken on her form at several points
but there was one major story in which
he actually became her for quite a
prolonged period
lady loki is based on the trickster's
ability to shapeshift
and actually pulls from nordic legend
namely the times that he would visit
earth and appear as an elderly woman
in the comics ragnarok was a big event
that pretty much
birthed the introduction of her as a
character and after asgard was destroyed
thor thought his people might have been
too however he discussed things with his
alter ego donald blake
and realized that the souls of the
asgardians had been displaced
and that they were actually inhabiting
new bodies thor found heimdall and with
his power to view everything in the
universe
he managed to track down the rest of the
asgardians
now it was thought that he had managed
to find sif
however upon arriving at a prison he
realized that loki had actually taken
over her body
lady loki said that the rebirth was a
second chance to do things over
and she said she would be a force for
good instead of evil
now this was a time in which secret
invasion had meant the government was
reshuffling all the powers that be
and tony stark was removed from his
position as a director of shield
norman osborne was put in his place and
it's strange because they couldn't trust
tony because he might be evil
but they replaced him with norman osborn
anyway osborne started to assemble his
own team called the cabal
and this was made up of several
supervillains including lady loki
emma frost neymar dr doom in the hood
lady loki started working with doom to
resurrect the enemies of asgard
and she also went back in time to when
boar the father of odin was frozen in
ice
loki actually changed events slightly so
that she could resurrect him in the
future
and she placed a spell on him to make it
so that he viewed everyone as an enemy
he went on a wild rampage and thor ended
up killing him
however he was technically the king of
asgard because he was on the throne
during his apparent death
and thus thor had just murdered the king
this meant that by
asgardian law he was banished and loki
eventually ended up becoming the ruler
sif was given the body he had taken over
and he returned to his normal form
this ended in all out war and loki did
end up dying once more but
as we've seen he's come back multiple
times and he was actually reincarnated
into the body of a parisian pickpocket
interestingly this version of lady loki
has one horn missing
which is similar the one that appeared
in loki agent of asgard
in that book the god of mischief was
given a second chance in a younger body
and he became a force for good that
ended up attempting to right the wrongs
of his past
now before the breakdown i also want to
draw attention to the time stone that
loki nabbed all the way back in episode
1
and we'll talk about how this could come
into play later on in the video
now the episode itself is called
lamentis which means to lament
groan or weep in latin however beyond
that in the comics it's a purple planet
that we end up spending a lot of time on
in this episode
now we open with the song demons by
hayley kayoko because
well we're dealing with horned gods they
also encounter
a woman who calls them devils and devil
imagery has of course been laced
throughout the show
from here we jump to sachalane c20 and
sylvie getting their drinks on
discussing brain freeze hilariously
sylvie doesn't suffer from this
as we know loki is of course a frost
giant and therefore wouldn't feel the
cold
throughout our breakdowns we've
discussed how there may be other
characters making cameos as slight
variants
and in episode 1 it was of course peggy
carter episode 2 had agatha and shout
out to christopher godins on twitter for
pointing out that we might get what
could be a cameo
of ralph bona i mean i mean quicksilver
definitely quicksilver
reality warps around them as we see
sylvie attempting to get to the bottom
of how many people
are guarding the timekeepers turns out
this entire scenario is a psychic
projection
which is actually another power that the
enchantress has
now cut to the title screen and shouts
patrick currier for pointing out that
this is
actually an effect that you get when you
photocopy something over and over again
this is known as generation loss and
over time if you keep copying something
the quality of it diminishes obviously
this speaks to the amount of variant
loki's that there are running around
and at one point in the entry loki even
refers to sylvie as a failed photocopy
from here selfie travels to the tva
headquarters but she's surprised to
learn that her powers don't work anymore
meaning that she likely hasn't been
there before or if she has
she wasn't in a position to use them now
this power set is of course very similar
to wonder
who is of course able to alter people's
minds and create fake realities
we saw her pulling off a similar move in
age of ultron and this is clearly the
skill set of a witch
loki asks her if she's sure she's a loki
and she says not to call her that
and at one point he even utters the line
and chant me
which now she says that she's now going
under the alias of sylvie
but as we know these are characters that
like to lie a lot so i think there might
be some surprises as we're still only at
the halfway point of the season
i think if we're just taking things at
face value then she's likely just a
combination of the characters
however it is worth bearing in mind that
her powers are similar to enchantress
no not that one it's never been that one
now after rent slayer shows up
they escaped to the planet lamentis 1 in
the year 2077
which is in the midst of its own
apocalypse the purple giant is currently
about to crash into a moon
and this event leads to there being
absolutely no survivors
though it initially seems to be like the
worst possible scenario they could be in
it actually allows for them to get to
know each other whilst they try and
power up the temp pad
after investigating the area they find a
woman living with a shock rifle
and did anyone else get get a bit of a
tear in their eye when loki pretended to
be her husband patrice
i miss you so much patrice just miss you
oh it's not really him is it now they're
directed to an evacuation vessel and we
can see that the upper class members of
society are being pushed onto this arc
first
whilst the poorer people are forced to
queue up arcs of course come from the
bible
and are typically referred to as ships
or boats that offer sanctuary in the
midst of an apocalypse
loki disguises himself as a god and
using sylvie's powers they're able to
sneak aboard the train
which gave me a lot of snow pierce of
vibes it very much exemplified how the
upper elite would step on the poor in
order to push themselves up
but how they didn't actually value them
or see them as being worthy members of
society
the train itself was referred to as an
arc and it is possible that this series
is giving a nod to both that comic tv
show and movie
now the pair have a really great back
and forth on screen and if they weren't
the same person
i actually wouldn't mind seeing them
hook up let's be honest though if
there's any person in the universe that
would go out with himself
it would probably be loki now he
discusses his past
namely his mother and also how he was
adopted which is of course
a big catchphrase for the character that
has appeared in several films including
the avengers
thor ragnarok and also infinity war loki
talks about how his mother used to turn
a flower into a frog
a magic trick that could be a nod to
when loki turned his brother into one in
the comics
the pair sort of interview one another
which might sound like weird phrasing
but there's a reason why i've used it
now before we get into the rest of the
video i just want to let you know i've
done a big interview with real rejects
discussing all the ins and outs of
youtube
what goes on behind the scenes and the
highs and lows of watching
25 hours of tv a day it'll be linked in
the description below so definitely go
and check it out after this
and also i was on holiday in the lovely
yorkshire dales for the week but the
internet was so crap i had to come back
home to do this video
so i'd massively appreciate the thumbs
up with mediocre breakdowns comes great
responsibility
and it would mean a lot to me as i do
this full-time and kind of rely on it as
a job so
much appreciated all your support there
cheers now back to the show and sylvie
says she had a wildly different
childhood to loki and says that she knew
she was adopted
potentially because she was old enough
to understand what was going on
if she is indeed a different character
it is possible that she was saved at a
much later date
but either way we can see how the pair
have had wildly different lives
now going off into the selfie
enchantress theory completely it is
possible that an older version of loki
picked her up when she was a kid
and gave her powers we know that richard
e grant is going to be in the series
and i think that he would definitely be
a perfect older variant of loki
agent of asgard actually features an
older version of the character
and he very much manipulates events in
order to ensure that the younger version
becomes him
if we look at the comics he might
actually be using selfie to destroy the
tva
much in the same way that oloki was
using the younger version of himself
in that to destroy asgard this could
also explain how she knew of the tva but
didn't realize that her powers wouldn't
work there
probably because she hasn't been there
and was told by this older version
which might not even be true so get off
that now
now silvie says she maintained a
relationship with a postman over the
centuries
and this could be a nod to david a
postman in the marvel universe that
ended up becoming the leader of the
morlocks
the pair discussed whether love is hate
and so on but loki eventually settles on
the metaphor that love is an imaginary
dagger
terrible terrible metaphor but i think
the series will very much
center around them trying to find
something to love
something to love 3 000 loki says that
he's had a bit of both
over the years probably the same as her
and shout out to all my lgbtq viewers
happy pride month guys now loki sings
his song and smashes a glass before
saying another which is something that
his brother did in the first thor movie
i also feel like he was singing this
song to sylvia to test if she was as
guardian
but i'm gonna just get off the fan
theory train right now as it's starting
to derail the video but a bit of a train
pun there now
it's all fun and games and eventually
the train guards show up
the pair go toe-to-toe with them and the
god of mischief is thrown off the train
and he adopts somewhat of a similar pose
to how he did in thor ragnarok after he
ended up falling for 30 minutes
unfortunately the fall has broken the
temp pad and the pair are now stuck on
the planet
loki mocks sylvia a bit and makes fun of
her for having a
quote-unquote glorious purpose which is
a phrase that he used in the avengers to
discuss the burden he had
however it was also something that was
the name of the first episode
showing that it's all connected now it
turns out that the orc never left the
planet because it was destroyed
and we get a big theory about the tva
confirmed
it's revealed that the minutemen are all
variants that have been pulled from the
timeline
had their memories wiped and then been
placed into a life of servitude
this is clearly why mobius laments his
jet ski
and he was likely pulled from the 90s
which is when the character was created
in the comics
now in the source material there were
actually several versions of him
and shout outs eric vos from new
rockstars for guessing this correctly
last week
now i forgot to mention last time that
the lucky variants we got
pulled from issue 3 of the mighty thor
amongst this image
we can see the hulking loki frost giant
one and the old school viking one
jason aaron actually posted this last
night and i haven't seen it mentioned in
any other breakdown so far
so this is an exclusive that we stole
but still an exclusive exclusive
now the pair head to the city to find
the moon breaking apart above them
and even though the planet is going to
hell there's still gods
running around trying to kill them you
gotta get that paycheck i suppose
god knows i cancelled my holiday to come
do this crap now
ignore on that it's an incredible
one-shot take that shows everything
being blown to hell
and as always the ark is destroyed as
predicted
this ends the episode and i think we can
guarantee that next time
we will be getting the shot from the
trailer of the pair sitting together
i was expecting this to happen this
entry but it looks like it'll be in the
next one for sure
now i kind of feel like we'll be getting
the vote loki story next time
and it could happen when the tva come to
rescue him the temp pad
isn't working so i think the most likely
way out for them is to be picked up by
their dear old friends
loki could end up telling mobius that
he's actually a variant
which may turn him against the tva it's
even possible that the quote-unquote
other person in the field who also
leaves ring stains in red slayer's
office
is another version of mobius and he make
him face to face with himself at some
point in the series
now going back to the beginning of the
video you have to bear in mind that loki
still potentially has a time stone
so he may even reverse the events of
this planet in order to get off of it
there's lots of things that could
potentially happen but obviously leave
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below
overall i kind of feel like this was a
weaker episode out of the three and
a bit fillery but it did give us the
chance to get to know the characters
better
selfie seems like a great person to be
on the same side as
and it's going to be interesting to see
whether they managed to take down the
tva or not
kind of like how we're getting a lot of
the things unfold slowly but with this
being at the halfway point in the series
now
i really hope that episode four and five
just go absolutely crazy with it
now as for the rest of the video i kind
of want to go over my thoughts on the
series so far
and talk about what could be coming down
the line tom hiddleston actually dropped
an interview talking about his thoughts
on episode 4 and 5
but i'll leave that until after the
review part in case you don't want to
know
at this moment this is my favorite mcu
show so far
the first episode i did enjoy but i felt
it was also a bit
exposition heavy but by the second i
absolutely loved it
and if you've watched my tennis videos
then you'll know i love anything
involving time travel
avengers end game was incredible for me
because it allowed the heroes to make
things right through the use of time
travel
but loki feels like he's using it to
potentially make things wrong
if that makes sense now elsewhere
stories have always been something i've
been fascinated with
and i'm very much looking forward to
what if because that is pretty much
gonna be an entire series of them
however loki is also showing several
what-if stories involving the god of
mischief
and we already know from the trailers
that more and more versions of him will
be popping up throughout the show
i think it's really gonna allow tom
hiddleston to show off all the
complexities of the character
whilst he also gets to cement how good
of an actor he is with his range
loki at this point is one of the most
fascinating characters in the mcu
because you don't really know what way
he's gonna go and i love that this show
is hammering this idea home
he could be a good guy could end up a
villain or maybe even
something in between that's what's great
about loki and there's so much potential
around what the character could do next
time
the show could really visit any point in
the past or future
and it's just making it something that's
so much fun to watch
i feel like every week it's getting
better and better and hopefully next
week we answer the question of what the
m in mobius and mobius stands for
now as for episode four and five
hiddleston did the press run for the
show
and he was asked by tick tock user
theory bites which of the episodes was
his favorite
hiddleston said it was a bit difficult
to tell as he loved them all
but said that anytime he worked with
owen wilson that it was a blast
however he did play his hands slightly
and said the following when discussing
what directions the series could be
going in
i think episodes four and five the two
together the whole series takes off in a
direction that i certainly didn't see
coming when i read it
i'm really excited for the audience to
see it so that's where we just
expand into new territory thanks for
coming on the show tom really really
nice to talk to you
now one of the big worries off the back
of one division and falcon in the winter
soldier
was that these shows wouldn't really
matter as both kind of ended the same
way that
end game left things wanda was still
depressed and by herself
and sam had become captain america this
show
has so much potential though they could
be setting up spider-man no way home
or even things in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
and hearing that four and five go off in
a totally new direction
it just gets me so excited now as for
what jonathan mages said about kang
he was asked by variety whether the
villain would be appearing in loki
before ant-man quantum mania
variety said that without even pausing
mages said
i have no idea what you're talking about
he's goddamn actors man
can't tell whether they're lying or
telling the truth but i would absolutely
love to see the villain pop up in the
show he's one of the best in the marvel
universe and
he's also connected to the tva i feel
like he is going to be connected to the
quantum realm and the multiverse
and with ant-man 3 being called quantum
mania and the city of granopolis
potentially appearing in ant-man in the
wasp
he may either be there or disguised as
the timekeepers
you may even get a post-credits scene
hint of him as i feel like he's going to
be the next thanos
in terms of the big threat in the mcu
time travel opens the door for so much
and of course with that always comes
kang obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show so far and if
there's any easter eggs or theories that
you have then yeah just just leave them
in the comment section below
as a thank you for commenting on the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode the winners of last
month's competition are on the screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of lady loki
which will be linked on screen right now
we sort of went over her history briefly
in this video but that one's a lot more
in depth so definitely check it out
after this
out of the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul
and i'll see you next time take care
peace